the bridge
[Music]
Call of Duty World War two's prestige
ranking system is similar to previous
iterations in the series but this time
includes more areas to max out than ever
before new to Call of Duty's multiplayer
are the five separate divisions that all
incorporate their own prestige leveling
system although prestiging divisions
resets all the class specific perks
you've earned the first prestige level
unlocks a unique division specific
weapon the five weapons not including
their cosmetic weapon variants are the
Infantry's svt40 the Airborne's mp40 the
mountains kar 98k the armoured mg42
and finally the expeditionary sawed-off
shotgun these weapons cannot be unlocked
with rank tokens or found inside loot
crate's so your only option is to grind
in multiplayer leveling each of your
divisions to the first prestige level is
not only a time-consuming process but it
also forces you to dive into classes you
might not be inclined to play normally
so with that being said here are our
thoughts on which divisional prestige
weapons are worth your time
not every Call of Duty player can agree
on which weapon they think is best but
we feel the majority would agree that
the Airborne's mp40 is a must-have even
without additional attachments the mp40
feels significant damage with a high
rate of fire and very light recoil if
you were a fan of submachine guns the
mp40 is the gun for you
[Music]
the semi-automatic weapons are a bit
underpowered in Call of Duty World War
two but the Infantry's svt-40 is still
the best of the bunch even though the
svt-40 has a low rate of fire it makes
up for it in the damage Department
deadly from both long to medium range a
mere two shots typically takes down your
opponent
[Applause]
although the m1903 is Call of Duty World
War two most powerful sniper in terms of
damage and range the mountain division's
kar 98k is only slightly less powerful
but steps up its accuracy we think it's
higher accuracy and large one-shot kill
zone makes the car 98 worth your time if
you spend most of your time stealthily
sniping around the battlefield see is
retreating
you must disco
see is a dancing is stop seas falling
back the Allies are securing the banka
banka bees on the move
kill a chess court
the armored class may not include a tank
in its loadouts but it does bring some
pretty big guns to the frontlines and if
all the LMGs offered the armored mg42
stands out combining the best sight
picture with decent reload speeds and
good ammo capacity the mg42
is the most well balanced light machine
gun offered in the game not to mention
it's also quite powerful
back
reinforcements
and finally if there was a single weapon
in Call of Duty World War 2 that
disappoints at almost every level it
would be the expeditionary sawed-off
shotgun its weak damage and terrible
range make this shotgun underwhelming in
every regard your best bet is to stick
with its big brother the m30
or take advantage of the combat shotguns
increased ammo capacity in short don't
waste your time with the sawed-off
we cut along we have eyes in the sky for
those currently grinding away in Call of
Duty World War two's multiplayer what
divisional prestige weapon is your
personal favorite and for more news and
updates as Call of Duty World War 2
releases its season pass stay tuned to
gain spot